il a lieu chaque année mais se prépare
bien en amont de manière minutieuse et
rigoureuse
le défilé aérien du 14 juillet rassemble
91 appareils hélicoptères avions
chasseurs différents aéronefs de l'armée
de l'air de la marine nationale de la
gendarmerie ou encore de la sécurité
civile avec une organisation
particulière le défilé qui est constitué
d'un ensemble de patrouille qui vont
attendre dans l'ouest parisien qu'on
leur donne le top départ est bien se
rejoignent petit à petit sur un axe qui
est la kz2 défilé et c'est bien par le
respect des altitudes le respect des
vitesses le respect des trajectoires le
respect des horaires
le respect des procédures radio que la
sécurité aérienne est garanti pour cette
journée à la base aérienne 107 de
vélizy-villacoublay tous les pilotes
chef de bloc sont réunis c'est le cas du
sous-lieutenant aurélien navigateur au
sein d'un awacs
un avion de l'armée de l'air doté d'un
radar charge à chacun dans son avion et
dans son son équipe de d'avion leader +
équipiers de préparer la mission au
mieux en traçant des cartes en préparant
visualisant sa mission avant et ensuite
pour être au rendez vous répétition
générale et le 14 juillet à l'heure sur
l'écran le navigateur en charge tout ce
qui va être la gestion de la trajectoire
avec les pilotes ainsi que le timing sur
chaque point de notre trajectoire
donc on est là vraiment pour assister
les pilotes et que puisse se concentrer
exclusivement à la main de la
manoeuvrabilité de l'avion
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
après le briefing du matin les pilotes
ont pu faire des repérages aborde
différents hélicoptères des points
d'identification de la défense à la
place de la concorde pour faciliter le
défilé pilote d'un mirage 2000d le
commandant nicolas sera suivi de cinq
mirage 2000d et de six rafale les
premiers repères qu'on essaie
d'identifier sont des repères avec des
développements verticaux qui nous
permettront en cas de mauvaise météo de
pouvoir nous affranchir de une
visibilité médiocre ou faibles donc
jusqu'à 5km de visibilité horizontale
pour pouvoir nous aligner sur la défense
et ensuite être axé parfaitement une
répétition générale du défilé aérien
doit avoir lieu fin juin dans le loiret